democrats think big government knows
best when it comes to your kids
education president biden riling up
concerned parents with what he just said
about who should be in charge of the
classroom
today there are too many politicians
trying to score political points trying
to ban books
even math books i mean did you ever
think even younger teachers you ever
think when you'd be teaching you're
going to be worrying about book burnings
and banning books
all because it doesn't fit somebody's
political agenda they're all our
children
and the the reason you're the teachers
of the air is because you recognize that
they're not somebody else's children
they're like yours when they're in the
classroom
and remember the billions of dollars
blue states said they needed to battle
covet turns out new york illinois
california and other states used some of
that money to push critical race theory
lesson plans not all the money went to
where they said it was going to go
but dana i think being the little tone
deaf here is the president just falling
into the same pattern that terry
mcauliffe fell into and said hey they're
our kids not your kids
they kind of make it easy like there
have been warning signs like hey make
sure you don't step on that particular
rake oh sorry oh not that one either and
then they keep doing it and hitting
themselves in the head i mean given this
type of thing you could imagine that
glenn junkin the governor of virginia
maybe he will run for president in 2024
if president trump decides not to run
because this was what brought virginia
to the republican side this very issue
so if the president wants to make these
arguments he just has to do it in a more
fulsome way you can't just have a
comment like this that is going to get
cut in the sound bite this is the world
that we live in it's going to be cut so
you have to make sure that you are being
very clear if that is not what you meant
on the money being spent on crt and not
other things i i'm mad about it i think
taxpayers should be mad about it but one
of the things is we have to make
congress be more accountable for how
this money is going to be spent that you
control the purse strings that means you
can tell people how they should spend it
and that included the ppp money which uh
what was it 500 billion dollars in fraud
half a trillion trillion dollars in
fraud for the ppp loans and then you
have this money that was supposed to go
to school so that we could improve the
ventilation systems and they've spent it
on this i can see why parents would be
mad i mean jessica it's 122
billion dollars that went to these
schools so they could reopen so they
could clean out the air ducts so they
could have the plastic dividers and
those types of things
and then they're out there doing the
very thing that is riling up so many
parents reason that parents are leaving
the democratic party i just i don't
understand how this administration could
continue to be so incredibly tone deaf
well i'm interested in actually seeing
you know the line from here's one dollar
and this is exactly where it went to
because if they're going they're
supposed to go to the school system and
i think that there's good reason to
think if it is a curriculum that employs
some degree of critical race theory but
you're using it to bolster the school
facilities and to pay teachers and keep
classrooms clean and whatever that i
guess i could technically go to that but
i'm sure that was that was clearly not
the intention when that money was
allocated to those 10 states in terms of
biden's comment i think we all
understand what he was trying to say and
i i don't think that it was anywhere
close to what terry mcauliffe said which
was that parents have no role in what's
going on with teachers or what goes on
in the classroom biden was making the
point that you as parents
would actually want teachers to feel
the same way that you do about their
kids to care for them to be nurturing
them to be taking responsibility for
them and providing a great service i i
don't think it's the same thing but to
dana's point everything gets cut up
everything is going in an ad and that's
not something we can afford to do
there's a big wall street journal piece
i think michael bender did it where he
interviewed democratic voters in new
jersey who are don't know who they're
going to vote for because of masking
kids in schools
and
uh they're just saying we're you know we
oh i have to
if they're so quick am i here sorry
anyway
but this is part of the the point judge
is look at what biden actually said he
doesn't get i want to pass the president
of the united states by saying well i
meant this i mean we do that everything
i want to tell you what he said
the children are ours when they're in
the classroom they're not somebody
else's children
wrong
my child is my child whether my child is
at home or in the classroom they are not
your children they are always my
children i give you the right to have
them in the classroom because i elect to
allow them in the classroom i elect to
have them taught in a public school and
i find this so incredible that that
biden is saying that the teachers are
really the victims here teachers are
being unfairly targeted that's a quote
from biden in the culture wars are you
kidding me the teachers are the ones who
said the parents were the terrorists and
the biden administration and the fbi ran
with it so the here is what i consider
to be the bottom line
that this is this is a new world order
we're now going to bring in the children
into part of the government there are
and we're going to decide what to teach
them and you parents we're not going to
tell you about that about it but if you
find out about it it's still none of
your business here's a here's a message
we pay the teacher's salary we provide
you with the product which is a child
and we have the right to decide whether
to send our child to your school or to a
private school or to teach them at home
and cut out the crap with oh there are
children and nobody else's stop that's
absurd it's custodial interference greg
custodial interference
that's great i'm using that tonight on
my show look there are great teachers uh
but but because of
i guess the teacher union leadership the
zoom meetings and social media they
aren't well present well represented
anymore we only hear from the crazy
teachers and again this is another arena
where wochism has really kind of
polluted and poisoned a really thing
that we used to love like when i was a
kid you thought your teachers were
magical right you know they taught you
cursive handwriting they they they were
like
they they treated you like they were
your kid but now you know who's majoring
in education are these very aggressive
activists who you know are obsessive
about identity and radicalism and they
don't they
i could understand concern if biden was
talking about the where the the children
were coming from broken homes or really
bad homes maybe there were no parents
but the problem is these prominent
voices in in the educa the world of
progressive education assume that
all children are problem children
because they don't like the parents and
the more that the parents care and the
more intrusive parents are about the
education the the more oppressive they
are seen by
liberal educators so it's like
they don't like the conflict that the
parents are giving there
so in fact they started the culture war
it wasn't the parents right they started
the culture war and the kids are the
cannon fodder
yeah
i i'm still stuck on the whole custodial
interference i want a shirt that says
custodial sounds like a steven segal
movie custodial interference the
reckoning
in moscow yes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else